لدينا 440 شخصًا وفي الساعة الخامسة صباحًا
يمكنك إطلاق مدفع في الشارع الرئيسي
ولن تصطدم بأي شخص هادئ
وغريب بعض الشيء هذه هي الكلمات
المستخدمة لوصف نغمة ويكوف التي
عاشها ومات في هذا  أدار Place Ed
Krueger متجر بقالة Jack Sprat
لمدة نصف قرن عندما توفي عن
عمر يناهز 91 عامًا. لقد أراد كل شيء
يمتلكه للبلدة تمامًا كما كان في كل مرة
أتيت فيها إلى هنا أرى شيئًا جديدًا
لم أره  قبل عدم معرفة ما يجب
فعله ، حول قادة المدينة حياة إد
وتخزينه إلى متحف ،
تطوعت بيكي لتناول قطعة حلوى
كانت موجودة هنا لمدة 50 عامًا ، لم يكن
تناولها كثيرًا على الرغم من أنني متأكد من
أنها لن تكون رائعة حقًا  في هذه
المرحلة ، ما سيحدث لك
بعد ذلك ، نعم في
الحفاظ على هذه المدينة هو باراماونت
لأن على بعد مبنيين
آخرين يوجد مبنى أيقوني آخر لم
يغير الكثير من ليندا أنت وأنا أحاول
تجنب السجن وفي بلدتك يريد
الناس البقاء في السجن  تريد البقاء نعم
هذا صحيح ، افتتح سجن ويكوف
في عام 1913. كان الحراس يتقاضون
عشرين دولارًا
شهريًا للعناية بالسجن الذي خدم
غرضه لمدة 50 عامًا وعندما
أغلق مجلس المدينة فكر في
هدمه ولكن في أوائل التسعينيات كان الأمر كذلك
تحولت إلى مبيت وإفطار ،
ثم قبل بضع سنوات ، وضعها موظف المدينة بيكي
شميدت على Airbnb
وانفجر ، أعني أنه أصبح مجنونًا في
العام الأول الذي حصلنا فيه على إيجارات
كل ليلة تقريبًا ، تساعد الأموال المتأتية من
الإقامة في السجن  تدفع المدينة مقابل
الصيانة هنا وفي Ed's Museum يمكنني أن أرى
أنك حصلت على ملاءات
مناسبة جدًا لسجن السجن إلى حد كبير ، كل شيء
في السجن أصلي على
الرغم من إضافة الحمام والدش ،
يجب على الضيوف الدخول في وضع الإغلاق يمكنهم
البقاء في زنزانة ضيقة بحيث
قبل قرن من الزمان ، ينام بعض الضيوف
حقًا يرتدون ملابس
لوقتهم خلف القضبان ويعرفون جيدًا
أن هذا هو عكس الفخامة ، فأنا
أخبرهم عبر الإنترنت أنك تعرف ما إذا كنت
أريد تاج محل ، هذا ليس هو ، أعني أن
هذا أمر خشن وهو سجن
حتى أن الزوار قد أتوا من جميع
أنحاء البلاد وبعيدًا مثل أستراليا
لمجرد قضاء الليلة خلف القضبان ، وهي عبارة عن
كتلة زنزانة عمرها 110 سنوات تضيف إلى
Wonder of Wyckoff ، إنه مجرد مجتمع ودود
لدينا مجموعة من
الكيانات الصغيرة الغريبة للترفيه عنك